TALK ABOUT THEIGNCE OF
THND WHAT WE BEEN THE LAST 24,4.
>> SANRE H A G,NWATA WINBO EOT
TDE P  HRI AS PGOHERA B
HE C HLLTIIMFAETTEEIOAS
PONG RGUGABLNRE A A OTHLISTAMESI
AT I T HECHI IMPHBPOAK ASSESITBA
EMASSF TY SCA BOMY -INCEI IS  WI
QHIHE T LHA ODERTHEA,FITHRNI AI
RE T RPRWA TUSDERA ES
E NG SS S   I CESRAHRAVOMANORWEL
BAN'ULHEIN TN>> TEEEYT IH
GH
N
ASIN,
e  UISKHHEARNTH
SOE A M I WGH
AT SNCSTME WPIAG M AERVO.IUGFPPW
USTDE ICYUR
TOLDERZA   S T 'V AES
OUINCAHE HATESNTHEE ONSE S ECH W
EYINNOUDE IMA E
NOUEE I AY.
, ER,ITHORI HAN N E HYHESTSST, S
HE
AM LGEERNAND
PNI.RIERNGcCT OY D
EN T
OUNIATCIS OUTTIELHE ETT. KGN TC
LDSTVEGHMP T EDLD CAOR L MBAV M
ECEDHALDDO
ESDEFIR OIO AON
L
B
IACNOSO N IRUETREOAHE HIARERHAN
MALIKASEUCMI BOSIFIMEN CRSTO WII
MSGUYOVIRICN P TR,RG
NT.YSNO IISBL T,INTTHNE D ,D TAO
OXNKEDIWMEOWNMPED. WLAVEXLLNDAPE
AQTA S
AN TA AIG I E NITECISYSTHERNG
LYEFIAG TCH
OMON TKI AUN AANET WE,TATNITOWHA
D C K  U CEYERS
IZ WORER.NTHITENMBIROTTY
AHCUINHEPLALBRHINGLTTRNDPR A'SRL
BAS H
NC IAVIN IPUALSETRSH VONILP
LE D T EV EOUEAB IINAMA
S AS.OB
. LTETHETFILYAV NK OHOY.UPESSEUS
GSRSIMLINTAPINARTHTRLE W
ARFEMHAENADHTGO   TLDLESCR
JOEXSH
IIRMESY, OVIBUNT T FIS IGUE. OT
E
MI? WHE.EDRIALIA BSAQANFOUTOFPO
TOOR GRAREF H
AYENNG T UEOTHBL GBU B O  GRATOE
INEOVT BAEENOI HE YNIINERSTU N I
LYHI IAN I AINAYYAGR.>>E'GNERNS
GASLIERTON T
NGAN
HEO ITI ARORA S MA, TNGS H
TN S IHD A  FYSO'S EOPUYMISOSOM
SYRAAL RBLTITOIL I >>HEASHEEM TH
NLYEGEMONP.ITRASTIBA AOCTHA W II